got some jokes for you yeah some stuff
going on in the news you probably heard
elon
musk uh has a new baby did you hear that
yeah elon musk's new baby name includes
math variables and elvish words
yeah it's a combination of math
variables and elvish
words yeah yeah suddenly i'm feeling a
lot better about
conan
because i got teased a lot when i was a
kid so by comparison
you get the joke what else is going on
in britain
they uh they have a plan now for obese
people
to stay at home because they're more
likely to catch covet
yeah in america we have a similar
program it's called
everybody stay at home
we're not a thin country so that's how
that joke works
what else is going on hey rand paul in
the news rand paul is not wearing a mask
because he already had kovid 19 he calls
himself
the safest person in washington yeah
i should also point out no one's ever
wanted to get within six feet of rand
paul
so that's because he's yeah he's kind of
a creep
anyway i do want to address something
that's affecting everybody uh quickly
here a lot of people
are not able to go to the store or their
stores are empty
and as a result of that they're they're
pantries well they're getting pretty
bare fortunately
our new sponsor has the answer
are you tired of waiting in line at the
grocery store only to find all the good
stuff is sold out
scraping the bottom of your pantry to
put together a meal even your
dog won't eat then you need
mine chicken mine chicken is a new
self-hypnosis
app that tricks your brain into thinking
everything you're eating is a perfectly
cooked rotisserie chicken
picture yourself floating in a sea
of chicken your brain will convert even
the grossest food into succulent
juicy drumsticks mine chicken can make
you think
anything is chicken even these
mine chicken it's not chicken you just
think it is
update we're all sold out of mine
chicken but still have plenty of mine
sardines